hi i'm sheikha ramanathan i'm a
professor at dartmouth college and today
i've been challenged to explain a topic
at five levels of difficulty
so what is quantum sensing
we're looking at the rules of
microscopic world which is quantum
mechanics and using those tools to help
us build the ultimate sensors which
means that they're as precise and as
accurate as the laws of physics allows
[Music]
what's your name namina our topic today
is quantum sensing so quantum is about
the study of stuff that's really really
really small and sensing is about
measuring so the word sensing comes from
kind of like our senses so do you know
what your five senses are seeing hearing
um tasting and smelling mm-hmm
yeah it touches touch exactly so it's
kind of really important for us to be
able to have these senses so we know
what's happening in the world around us
right we're doing quantum sensing is
we're trying to measure things that can
be hard to see let me show you can you
see inside it with your eyes no
okay can you bounce it for me
do you know what makes it bounce i think
like inside of it it's foam that's
fluffy but my second answer is i think
it's very soft
that's a great description can we cut
one open and see what it looks like yeah
i think that's a good idea here's a bowl
that's been cut right in half you look
inside it's hard this what gives it a
certain texture kind of like the texture
of like the top of a crayon but you were
right that it was like foam
it would be really cool if we could see
inside the ball
without cutting it open right but you
could use a magnifying glass and then
look at the ball but with the magnifying
glass you'd only be able to see it's
right near the surface right just you
won't be able to see into the middle if
you had the right tools you could start
thinking about ways to look inside the
ball without cutting it open that would
then you'd still have your ball we could
still play with it yeah it would be cool
if we like use something like an x-ray
we built an x-ray that was only made for
both and you could see everything inside
it every single detail you could zoom in
and out in it and you could draw it
print it out that's exactly the type of
thing that we're doing we're sensing is
we're trying to measure what's inside
with right and do it without destroying
the ball yeah for example we want to go
inside let's say the human body and see
what's happening sometimes we can look
under the surface of the earth and see
what's underneath it we can make really
really precise clocks that will tell us
that can measure time really really
accurately and we can make very very
fine measurements that'll tell us about
the rules of science and how the world
works around us but we need to build
better tools that allow us to do that
[Music]
our topic today is going to be quantum
sensing have you ever heard of it before
no no
what do you think it might mean
if you just break down the words
something on a very small scale because
of the word quantum the sentencing part
i'm not sure so sensing is really just
about measuring stuff okay and at some
level there's a different set of rules
that seem to come into play as you can
have particles at very microscopic
scales seem to do really strange things
but one of the quests of quantum sensing
is to harvest some of these unique
properties at the micro scale we are
really interested in quantum sensors
because we think they can give us the
ultimate limit of sensitivity so they're
really really sensitive to small changes
but they're also going to be really
reliable every time i make the
measurement they'll always get the same
results okay measurements on like what
kinds of things could be in almost
anything you want have you ever had
broken a bone i fractured something
though okay do you remember having an
x-ray yeah x-ray and i have had a few
mris before you've had an mri mris
before and so both of those are in some
ways a form of sensing and they rely on
different types of sensing
do you know what this image is maybe an
mri
exactly do you know what an mri how an
mri works
no i don't and i feel like i should
because i've gotten them millions of
times and what the mri scanner is doing
is it's measuring the signal from all
the water molecules that are present and
specifically the hydrogen atom in our
bodies we have these hydrogen atoms are
essentially spinning around magnetic
fields all the time and we just don't
know them so in some sense you've
already used a quantum sensor yeah so
our mri is essentially more detailed
x-rays they're not so they're giving us
different types of information okay so
this is an x-ray you don't see any of
the soft tissue the x-ray gave us
information about the bone yeah whereas
mri is giving us information about
things like the softer tissues yeah and
in fact we don't see the bone very well
and yeah so there are slightly different
reasons why you would choose a two
different things suppose i could have a
higher resolution what would you think i
would be able to see the different atoms
and the structures of the particles
start to see the different cells and
yeah the different chemicals in the
cells if you look at the mri images you
can see that they give you the broad
features of what the tissue looks like
but if you want to zoom in a little bit
more and see what's actually happening
inside a tissue or inside a cell and you
need a different type of sensor it's
going to be more sensitive and for
something like that you're going to need
a quantum sensor are there different
types of quantum sensors for different
things so one of the quantum sensors
that's related to the work that i do is
based on these defects they're called
nitrogen vacancy centers in diamond and
people actually now make nanodiamonds
that they can try to put inside the
human body to look at the chemistry
inside the cell so is that used for drug
trials and when testing out new
treatments we can do it on tissues right
now or on the surface but we can
actually do it inside the body so right
now we're struggling for which scenarios
can we use this to get better
information and when can we not do it
are there any other quantum sensors at
the moment that aren't in the
developmental stage anymore that we are
using so there are quantum sensors that
are sold for very specific applications
one of them is a magnetometer and those
can be really really sensitive to
measure small variations in magnetic
fields
that are trying to develop sensors that
are gravitational sensors right now we
have no way of probing what's under the
ground without digging into the ground
you talked about a sensor measuring
magnetic fields what does that help us
learn what is that good for well if i
want to navigate and i know what the
structure of the earth's magnetic fields
are in some ways that's how birds uh
navigate the avian compass in fact
people think of that as a quantum sensor
okay so they've got like built quantum
centers they have a built-in sensor and
one of the ideas is that they're using
quantum phenomena to figure out what the
direction of the earth's magnetic field
is that's why they're able to be the
homing pigeons are able to come back
yeah operational looking oh that's cool
what year are you in i'm a senior i'm
studying physics right now cool
what do you think of when you hear the
words quantum sensing i think that using
some sort of quantum computing
to
sense
some
quantum level
molecules or particles
like interactions and stuff maybe is
exactly using a quantum phenomena to
sense and measure things and the idea is
that if i can harness quantum phenomena
and i can push the limits that are
possible i can get something that's
ultimately more precise and potentially
more accurate okay
how is it more precise
we believe quantum mechanics tells us
what the true laws of physics are and so
a quantum sensor in that sense would
reach the limits of what's attainable it
would be the top tier it would be the
top tier what are what are you doing
like what are what are you
so i study spins and so spins are one of
the platforms that people have suggested
is a useful platform for building
quantum technologies and i study spins
on the solid state and one of the
platforms i work on is nitrogen vacancy
centers in diamond which is a really
nice platform because it the spins show
their quantum properties even at room
temperature so are you studying the
spins of the electrons so in some sense
the phenomena we're studying are
essentially is nuclear magnetic
resonance or electron spin resonance
which is a very similar phenomena but
uses the spin of the electron rather
than the spin of the the nuclei so you
mentioned the the diamonds that are used
to create the sensors right so how long
does it take to make a sensor and and to
make that diamond is that created do you
like put energy into it or so you can
implant nitrogen into a diamond and then
you bombard it with electrons to create
the vacancies and then you heat it up
and anneal it and then you get these
nitrogen vacancy centers in your system
so you mentioned quantum computing
earlier so have you heard of the the
idea of superposition
yeah so that's in some ways the key to
both quantum sensing as well as quantum
computing it's the idea that you can
take a system and put it in a
superstition of two states normally we
think of classically a bit can be a zero
or a one so switch is either on or off
whereas in a quantum system it can be in
what's called a superposition so it can
be in partially on and partially off but
one of the challenges with quantum
systems is that these superstitions are
really hard to maintain because we don't
see superpositions in the world around
us at one computer you try really hard
to isolate everything so that you can
maintain this quantum property
and the fact that it's actually going to
lose its quantum properties as it
interacts with the world also makes it a
great sensor because now you're actually
that you're using that fact that it's
interacting with the world to say wait
it's sensing something okay so it's like
using
like the quantum computer would be kind
of like the base
level and then like you take it out into
the world and see how like it differs so
rather than trying to build a lot of
complex algorithms and gates with it
what you do is you take these quantum
bits and you take them out into the
world and say
what do you see what are you sensitive
to so you can use an idea called
entanglement to make an even more
sensitive quantum sensor but that's even
more fragile so there's always this
trade-off between being super fragile
and being super sensitive how does
entanglement um work into it so
entanglement is the idea that two
particles are correlated they're
essentially in the same quantum state so
that you can't disturb one particle
without disturbing the second particle
and so if i have a large number of
quantum sensors are entangled
then they're all going to interact much
more strongly than if i just had one of
them interact at a time okay and so that
gives you a boost in sensitivity
it's more precise absolutely is an
atomic clock a quantum sensor in some
ways it is and atomic clocks are
remarkable devices and being able to
measure time that precisely has really
important consequences in fact our old
gps system is based on the accuracy of
atomic clocks certain set of satellites
each of which has an atomic clock on
board and they send out a time stamp and
so once it gets a signal from three
different satellites it can triangulate
and figure out exactly where you are now
if you could make those clocks even more
precise you could actually accurately
position where you are even more
accurately okay that's really cool so
some ways you know when atomic clocks
were
designed and built we didn't necessarily
think of gps but technology often works
that way is that there are new
discoveries and then someone else comes
along and says hey
this is a great tool for some other
application
[Music]
so what drew you into quantum computing
i think what got me into material
science was actually making
semiconductors for
solar panels then that drew me into new
types of technology that used
semiconductors with the one that's very
popular now as quantum computing and
what about you what got you interested
in quantum sensing i started out doing
magnetic resonance study things like
bone and biomedical magnetic resonance
ended up playing with spins for a long
time and the physics of spins just
fascinated me so what do you think is
a big difference between
imaging
large biological objects versus
sensing very small quantum objects i
guess in a way it's part of the same
continuum what you're doing is changing
the technological platform
and you're actually able to probe it
more sensitively the resolution you're
able to get is much higher so you can
see smaller signals in a much smaller
volume how is the resolution higher so
it's because the the nitrogen vacancy
center is a single defect so you can
actually see a single electron in normal
magnetic resonance you it's you don't
have the sensitivity in order to be
sensitive to like a single electron do
you have to be really close to it you
have to be close to it you can detect it
optically because if we tried to detect
the magnetic moment of the electron we
wouldn't be able to do that because
there the energy is too low compared to
thermal energies but what the diamond
system gives you is a natural up
conversion energy so you can couple into
an optical photon which is then much
easier to detect a single optical photon
than it is to detect microwave okay i
see yeah and that's why it's able you're
able to do it at room temperature as
well what are some of the challenges
you've faced when trying to do quantum
sensing with this platform one of the
key challenges i think for all
any quantum technology is really
understanding what limits your coherence
times and then the next question that
comes up often is
how do we make this better if i take a
single qubit or a single spin there's a
certain limit up to its sensitivity but
if i can take entangled spins in
principle i could make the system much
more
sensitive
but it usually comes at a cost because
when i entangle something it's much more
sensitive to decoherence as well in a
similar way but maybe even in the
opposite way where we want to
figure out how to be as resilient from
noise and all the kinds of noise sources
exactly okay what are you studying i'm
studying superconducting qubits they use
hybrid semiconductor superconductor
structures
the semiconductors are you introducing
new noise sources potentially that might
affect the coherence times yeah yeah so
the big one is charge noise because i
guess a lot of the superconducting
qubits they have made them in such a way
that they're insensitive to charge
exactly
so when you think of noise
in what way it is is a noise bad for
your system i usually think of it like
well we work with quantum systems yeah
and
those are very sensitive to fluctuations
i guess any fluctuations
can
kick your quantum system either out of
the state that it's in to another state
i think as you said you know anything
that interferes with my signal is noise
but it can come from
different sources in some ways
the operation of the quantum system
itself as it's sensitive to different
physical phenomena the ones that i don't
like i call noise the ones i do like i
call signal and that's an artificial
definition that i'm making when i choose
to build a sensor one of the challenges
we have is we're trying to figure out if
i want to control it
where is it coming from i remember we
had experiments running in our lab one
day and
we were running these experiments about
100 megahertz all of a sudden we saw
these big spikes coming in and we
realized we're picking up the local fm
stations
and that was a source of noise like it's
completely random but it is still there
and then the other form is very much
what is intrinsically within your
experiment itself because some of the
materials that you have have defects
that are coupling into your sensor into
your quantum system and are also
producing noise but yeah the interesting
stuff really is where you're picking up
the quantum noise from intrinsically
from whatever right it could give you
information if you read it out
about what's happening or you have to
find smart ways to suppress it so that
you can focus on what you really do care
about so what are the kind of
noise and fluctuations that you're
worried about so one of the things that
we're interested in is looking at
suppose i want to build an entangled
quantity sensor
when i put a number of spins together in
addition to being sensitive to an
external field they're sensitive to each
other and they start talking to each
other you don't just see the external
spins you see the fluctuations of all
the other spins in your system so what
you want to do is make sure that they
don't interact with each other but they
still stay sensitive to everything else
and there you could think about the
local interactions the magnetic
interactions between the spins as a form
of noise in some ways it's interfering
with what you want to measure which is
the magnetic field outside the sample
so our topic today is quantum sensing
which you're an expert on can you recap
for us in your perspective what is
quantum sensing
that's that's a million dollar or maybe
a billion dollar question exactly yeah i
think a lot of people in the field have
different definitions for it absolutely
what would you want to be like the
smoking gun of a quantum sensor depends
on who i'm talking to right you know
trying to talk to students and get them
excited or you know try to talk about
the elements of quantum mechanics i
think maybe we could agree that you know
things that use superposition have a
certain degree of of quantum mechanics
quantum yes involved maybe they should
be using elements of quantum computation
so i don't have a strong view on it but
i do think it's an interesting question
i would tend to agree that i think
in some sense all anything that uses
superposition could be quantum sensor
but then spectroscopy uses
superpositions and has been around for
60 70 years i think what excites me most
now is the idea that
can we push the boundaries of how
sensitive one can make this technique
how improving sensitivity specificity
what other limits and as we define it
better are there fundamental physical
limits that's where the
excitement lies is when we really start
to leverage
having you know access to individual
quantum degrees of freedom whether
that's a single photon or a single spin
and in principle then you could also
imagine entangling it and you know doing
some quantum computations on it in order
to make it an even better sensor so do
you think there's a maximum number of
spins you can have if i think about a
single nv as a register right i mean
people have thought about this it's an
interesting question you can think about
you have the electron and it's
surrounded by some nuclei and you could
change the density of those nuclei and
so if it's a lot more dense then you
have a lot more that are strongly
coupled yeah but you also have a lot
more noise
but i i don't know that there's
necessarily a limit i mean it's been it
keeps expanding i mean i think that
there are some groups that are able to
identify
you know 30 40 individual nuclear spins
around a single a single electron and
control 10 or 15 of them so do you think
you can integrate multiple
nv centers on multiple optical sensors
so are there ways in which you can
overcome this question of there's a spot
size and that limits how many nvs i can
pack into a certain region that's
another great question a couple of
groups actually that are working on
trying to read out the spin state of nv
centers uh electrically instead of
optically if you could do that then you
could pack a whole lot more into a
smaller space using tiny electrodes
and you could possibly have them spaced
at nanometer scales instead of at micron
scales and i think the application there
is clearly sensing right right
do you think they'd retain their
coherence times if you pack them in yeah
what's limiting the coherence is really
local right you know nanometer scale but
it happens to be that most of the time
when we try to read them out with light
well then the trouble is that the
diffraction limit of light is you know
hundreds of nanometers and so then we
need them to be apart but you know if
you have two envy centers that are more
than a couple tens of nanometers away
from each other they just don't talk to
each other yeah
so from that point of view the
technology could be really dense right
which is why you know some you know
companies or groups are trying to make
quantum computers based on spins and
semiconductors because they could be
really densely integrated using modern
technology but the question for a sensor
is as you say how do you address it how
do you initialize it how do you read it
out and is optics the best way to go it
may not be
if we think about
uh quantum sensing in particular it
really involves understanding materials
um solid-state materials chemicals you
know chemistry biology engineering
electrical engineering optics photonics
i mean so many different areas i think
that that's one of the most exciting
things about that is the degree to which
it's engaging a much larger
cross-section of scientists they're the
ones that i think are going to come up
with the breakthroughs of saying oh wait
i could design this molecule to do this
thing yeah and that i think is going to
make real breakthroughs in the next 10
years is the fact that we're just having
this much larger group
of scientists people bring in very
different perspectives into what used to
be a very niche feeling i remember
physics you'd only talk to people in
your subfield and now we're picking up
the phone and talking to people in the
different departments completely
different areas and
we're forced to learn different
languages
the quantum world is essentially the
world of very small but one of the
quests of quantum sensing is to harvest
some of these unique properties
at the micro scale and with these tools
we will be able to have new technologies
and new measurements that we are unable
to make today